[Music]
you sit very very often especially in
football batting patches here there
gambling companies not just on the front
of shirts on the side of shirts the
pitch side hoardings you see those
strange messages in entire Vietnamese
and Chinese and nobody understands what
is going on here I don't think the
football clubs really realize the
provenance of the company that is
actually sponsored in there should who
do the Premier League clubs actually
deal with are they dealing with the
brand these companies they're using
shell companies to hide their own ship
structure so the whole thing is a Dodge
I'm a football fan and like all fans I
used to recognize the sponsor on my
club's shirt nowadays not so much the
premier league has the biggest players
the best teams the widest TV audience
but have clubs been taking money from
betting Brands who operate in countries
where gambling is illegal to find out I
teamed up with my colleague Taro from
Nikkei in Japan and worked with ft
journalists and experts from across
Europe
illegal gambling is probably today the
biggest criminal operation in the world
this explosion of illegal betting in
Asia the number of illegal betting
operators some of the money being
invested in sponsorship in sports clubs
could be the proceeds of crime
[Music]
let's start with some context in China
all gambling is illegal except the
national lottery and some casinos in a
few select jurisdictions you can't even
advertise gambling products and that's
where football comes in
China boasted over 200 million football
fans in 2022 that's a lot of eyeballs
making football the perfect platform for
overseas advertising aimed at Chinese
customers within China
if one was to run an online particularly
an illegal online operator and you would
like to get yourself or your brand or
Brands notice in China One of the most
popular way or common way is to
advertise on European soccer channels or
soccer events it's watching that TV
coverage seeing the sponsorship of a
betting company and then that drives
people to go online immediately and bet
through that betting operator so we're
putting ourselves in a position we're
this advertising in a foreign country is
facilitating very often illegal activity
our premier league has been used as the
billboard no it's it's got to stop
just to be clear we're not saying that
every Premier League betting brand
targeting Chinese customers is illegal
advertising gambling products is
perfectly legal in the UK and there are
Chinese diaspora communities all across
Europe and Beyond but we wanted to know
whether it was these communities that
were being marketed to or whether the
money paying for sponsorship deals could
ultimately be coming from illegal
sources within mainland China we also
wanted to know how much Premier League
clubs our clubs really know about the
brands they help to advertise
the Premier League doesn't impose its
own standards on clubs when it comes to
vetting potential sponsors it's up to
each Club individually and none of the
clubs we approach were willing to tell
us how they go about due diligence in
any detail
so we looked into the betting Brands
themselves and who owns them what we
found was a tangled web of closed doors
dead ends and companies within companies
[Music]
138 was one of the very first Brands to
try to experiment with a globalization
of that Asian market people talked about
them because they sponsored Watford for
example
138.com is a new gaming brand we were
looking for a football club to become
the shirt sponsor of that was a club
with a plan going somewhere a little bit
different
the man you just heard from is called
Garth Kimber he was the public face of
138.com when it signed sponsorship deals
with Watford FC and Newcastle United in
2013 but he wasn't the owner of that
brand it's not quite that simple 138.com
is just a name it needs a company behind
it to get its gaming license file
trademarks register websites and so on
in this case that company was called
fesuge limited and the company behind
that was Zella Holdings Garth Kimber was
the director of Zella Holdings but
getting at who ultimately owned Zella
Holdings that was our first dead end now
we have to make a distinction between
the owner on paper and the actual owner
or the actual beneficiary it could be a
company that offers the service of being
the public uh facing uh owner but it is
actually held for someone else or it
could be that it is the vehicle that
does the administrative work for the
ultimate owner of the brand we're
talking here people who know the system
absolutely inside out they know the
people to contact they know what kind of
uh hurdles you've got to overcome
believe me it's actually more
complicated than you think
in 2013 Zella Holdings was described in
a trade magazine as the online arm of
one of macau's leading VIP junket
operators Sun City
Sun City group has been variously linked
to Triad groups has been accused of
being a front for money laundering and
its former CEO in January Alvin Chao was
jailed for 18 years he was charged with
fraud involvement in illegal gambling as
well as involvement in organized crime
when we're talking about their online
illegal betting in the mainland Sun City
was handling bets worth one trillion RMB
a year which exceeded the the bets that
went through China's national lottery
the rewards are just so huge but whether
Zella was in fact part of Sun City and
ran the brand 138.com on its behalf is
extremely difficult to prove and that's
because of where it's based it's on the
Isle of Man a small island in the Irish
sea that has access to the UK Market but
with its own government and its own laws
[Music]
the Isle of Man has an act which
basically allows you if you feel
uncomfortable revealing your ownership
of something you can nominate a
shareholder in your place so you end up
with shell companies you end up with
shell companies that go nowhere because
you cannot find out definitively who the
owners are everything it's like one of
those Russian dolls
where countless
companies are used in as screens
companies which are almost always based
in tax Havens with the British Virgin
Islands being a prime candidate for that
the British Virgin Islands will afford
an extra level of they won't like me
saying this but secrecy and if you don't
have law enforcement Powers it'll be
much harder to find the information
so where does this leave us we knew
Zella Holdings was based on the Isle of
Man so we pulled company documents from
there
all that told us is that Zella Holdings
was owned by another company called
Zella BVI where was that company
registered the British Virgin Islands
that means that without a court order we
can't access who owned that company or
ultimately the people behind Zella and
the 138.com brand
we asked Garth Kimber whether Zella
Holdings was ultimately owned by Sun
City as the trade Magazine from 2013 had
claimed he didn't answer the question
directly but categorically denied any
involvement in illegal betting
activities and said he had consistently
abided by the laws and regulations of
all jurisdictions in which he operated
but we found evidence of links between
Zella Holdings and a number of Sun City
subsidiaries
[Music]
there was a dispute with regards to a
domain name called sunbet.com and and
that really gave us some very
interesting insights uh more puzzle
pieces as to how these companies all fit
together
in that dispute Zella Holdings it's
described as the corporate regulatory
arm of sun Ventures development
this seemingly insignificant line in a
2014 panel decision by the world
intellectual property organization set
us on a trail by looking at Sun
Adventures development limited we were
introduced to a whole new cast of
companies within Sun City's orbit
there was a whole other Universe of Sun
City Affiliated companies and some of
these had the word sun in their name or
would use something quite similar to the
Sun City logo there was a contractor to
Sun Ventures development which filed
some corporate filings in in the
Philippines and was interesting there is
when you actually looked at the logo
that was displayed on the paperwork it
was the same logo the same Sun image
that Sun City the casino group was using
chakwa was the Philippines license
holder for three Sun City websites from
2008 and when you look at the
shareholders of chakwa one of those
shareholders was also on the board of
sun International which is another Sun
City affiliate company
all of these connections suggest Sun
Ventures development limited may have
been a subsidiary of Sun City which
could provide another potential link
between Zella Holdings and suncity
itself
we found the LinkedIn profile of the
person who represented sunventures
development Limited in the domain name
dispute it suggested that he worked for
Sun City at the time but we couldn't get
hold of him there was no number or email
address for him no response on LinkedIn
we even tried reaching him through
colleagues at his current workplace
nothing and again because of where Sun
Adventures development was registered we
weren't able to get hold of its owners
Sun Ventures was registered in the
British Virgin Islands we don't have the
shareholders but we have some names of
directors which would suggest that
they're probably Asian but that's where
the Trail Ends so we have these
connections from Sun City to some
Ventures development from some Ventures
to Zella Holdings from Zella to 138.com
we asked Garth Kimber Watford FC and
Newcastle United about these links none
were willing to comment on them
specifically
we did get a statement from Watford
which said the club employs a rigorous
process of due diligence involving both
its internal legal team and external
legal advice to ensure absolute
transparency where commercial partners
are concerned
but we still had questions
if there was even the suggestion that
these Brands could be connected to
illegal gambling operations in the Far
East how could they be allowed to
advertise in Great Britain how do they
even get their licenses it turns out
most of today's asian-facing betting
sponsors gain licenses to advertise in
the UK through something called a white
label
[Music]
at its Essence a white label provider
applies for and gets a gambling
commission license to provide services
in the UK market then it sells its
services on to Brands gambling brands
that may be based anywhere in the world
and with that all the due diligence that
the gambling commission the regulator
would do into these Brands immediately
just Falls and drops a level so the
gambling commission just to use this UK
example has has made it incumbent upon
those white label license holders to to
check the sub licenses but unfortunately
the white labeling system enables the
primary license holder to take
responsibility but not actually exercise
that responsibility this is clearly
exposed by earlier this year tgp Europe
which is the biggest white labeling
operator for most of the betting
Partners in the Premier League is hit
with a 3 300 000 pound plus fine by the
gambling Commission in part because it
didn't do enough due diligence on these
companies with the gambling industry and
the way that the white the white labels
operate it is murky they are not
um adequately
scrutinized and I don't think the public
know anything about that in a compliance
and enforcement report from 2020 the
gambling commission itself admits there
is a concern that unlicensed operators
who would potentially not pass the
commission's initial licensing
suitability checks are looking to use
the white label model to provide
gambling services in Great Britain
therefore the commission insists it is
essential that ukgc license holders
conduct appropriate due diligence checks
on their prospective white label
Partners before entering into a business
relationship but that ultimately
responsibility for compliance will
always sit with the license holder
so in effect the gambling commission
only looks into the White Label provider
itself and not the partners that
provider then deals with in this case
that why labor provider is tgp Europe
and when we tried to find out who was
behind tgp Europe we found a very
interesting press release from one of
its contractors
it was announcing a partnership with tgp
and they said
tgp part of TTP Holdings which itself is
part of the Sun City group and when you
find that it's like a Eureka moment
those allegations that had been kind of
floating around in the media for a while
I put to both Garth Kimber and to Steve
templeman who on company's house on
publicly accessible records is one of
the directors of tgp Europe both of them
categorically denied any links to Sun
City or or Alvin Chow but there's very
little ways of verifying that
because there's not a huge amount that's
clear about exactly how their ownership
structure works back about a decade ago
2013 2014 there was a company called tgp
Holdings that half owned tgp Europe
whose owners the real Ultimate owners we
didn't quite know to begin with it was
held in multiple use shell companies
then that got changed and the assets
were put into trust the assets have been
reassigned as it were and now it's been
dissolved so we don't really know who
the owner of that company tgp holding
was the trusts that were used to
dissolve tgp Holdings might have stopped
us getting to the company's ultimate
owners but they also gave us a clue they
were the same trusts used to dissolve
Zella BVI the shell company behind Zella
Holdings and138.com
could the same people be behind both
sets of companies and could that be Sun
City
we found a statement from the gambling
Commission in 2017 in which the
regulator called tgp Europe and fesuge
limited accompanied that ran 138.com
under Zella Holdings part of a single
group of companies but when we asked the
gambling commission what it meant by
this it contradicted the original
statement saying they were owned by
separate companies that were owned by
some of the same owners
then when I lodged the Freedom of
Information request to reveal the names
of the companies and owners in question
the commission decided to withhold that
information among the reasons it gave
the following really jumped out at me
the public trust that the commission has
robust processes in place to assess
operators so that when they use the
services provided by an operator they
are confident that there has been
sufficient scrutiny of that operator to
ensure that they are protected if this
information were released it would
undermine that confidence we consider
that the public interest is better
served by withholding this information
I'm not gonna lie I was pretty stunned
by this response the UK's regulator
refused to reveal what it knew about
138.com and tgp Europe's owners under a
freedom of information request because
it felt that it would undermine public
trust in its ability to do its job and
yeah after all the effort we've gone to
it was frustrating to be denied this
basic information
beyond that this whole episode raised an
even bigger question if we can't find
out who ultimately owned these brands or
even the company behind their licenses
then can the clubs really know who
they're dealing with
there was evidence from another Asian
betting brand that threw this into doubt
they love having signing ceremonies
and I noticed that there was a couple of
guys who were appearing there chief
executive Chief marketing this Chief
Operating Officer blah blah blah blah
and one of them was particularly present
one Dean Hawks
he was a male model
[Music]
Dean Hawks didn't respond to our
requests for comment but we could see
from his social media that he's modeled
for some of the world's leading Brands
and featured in several Chinese language
campaigns in 2019 he also featured in
promotional videos for major football
clubs across Europe each time standing
in for a genuine CEO or representative
of a betting brand called yabo suddenly
they were everywhere but I mean
absolutely everywhere in terms of the
Partnerships the portfolio was
unbelievable
[Music]
but did the clubs think they were
dealing with yabo or with somebody else
one clue was in the Manchester United
2020 annual report which describes one
of its Global sponsors as Tia nude
brackets yabo
one of the other important documents was
the announcement of a prized draw using
Diablo as the trade name but actually
behind it is xianu technology and this
was out of the 2019-2020 Premier League
season we don't know how much money
Manchester United received in
sponsorship funding from chanyu and some
estimates have put it around about 3
million Mark so therefore we would
expect there'd be quite a lot of money
in chanyu in order to be able to sponsor
a Premiership clubs and that wasn't the
case in its first year it made the
equivalent about around about 30 you
know 35
000 pounds in revenue and the following
year it was around about the 130
000 pound Mark that then made us
question is it actually their money that
is paying for the sponsorship
in response to our questions Manchester
United said that the agreement with yabo
which later rebranded to HDH complied
with UK law and that before any
partnership agreement is completed the
club undertakes a thorough internal and
external due diligence process
the spokesperson made no mention of
tianyu though nor any other company
behind the brand
so where was the money coming from
we knew from records found in the
Philippines that chanyu was based in
Manila we also knew the company had
placed several job adverts asking for
Chinese speakers and lodged alien work
permits enabling Chinese citizens to
work out of its offices why could it be
that Channel's employees were doing
something in the Philippines that was
illegal in China and could that be proxy
betting
foreign
because betting in in most Asian
countries is largely not legal or has
very limited legal betting opportunities
people would bet with someone they know
which is an agent and that agent might
handle free customers or five customers
or 20 customers they don't only meet
people in bars and pubs to take bets
they they open accounts for their
customers online so it was a local
business when it's physical but then
suddenly you can have customers across
Asia so if there's not any casinos in
China or any legal casinos people are
instead using technology to bet via
proxy in casinos abroad it's definitely
been something that has been a massive
thing in China and extremely popular but
more and more difficult to control one
of the easiest things ways of operating
that that they found is also for
geographical reasons is to go to the
Philippines you can acquire a license
there then what you do
you take some office space and you move
chinese-speaking Personnel into those
offices so they can actually interact
with the customers and then from there
your
personal telemarketer for one of a
better term your personal relationship
they would guide you through the process
of accessing the actual gaming platform
that usually Chinese youths India mid to
early mid-20s to early 30s and that
basically reflects the target market
segment that they're going for proxy
betting is seen as a way for Chinese
operators to take bets from customers in
mainland China while basing themselves
abroad or to put it another way to break
Chinese law while evading the country's
authorities
but is this what employers of chanye
were doing when they traded as yabo and
sponsored Manchester United
Taro and I contacted as many Channel
Representatives as we could find those
who were willing to talk to us said they
couldn't remember or couldn't provide
any details about the company's clients
or dealings but we did find evidence of
another gambling operator also called
yabo which was dismantled by the Chinese
authorities in 2021 for running across
border gambling syndicate
with this Diablo what the authorities
alleged against them was that they had
employed senior staff and based them
overseas and that they had also
recruited
um you know Chinese speaking staff
within China separately to work on some
of these operations that were based
overseas the Chinese authorities were
able to identify identify 80 000 agents
working in mainland China 80 000 and
these agents
have themselves Affiliates so it's a
pyramidal system
so it becomes incredibly difficult to
find out who is doing what
when they're at their height in 2019
almost 60 percent of people working in
Philippines offshore gaming operators or
pogos were from China and almost half of
all bets placed through them were in
Chinese Yuan
since then serious crimes attributed to
pogos have quadrupled including human
trafficking and kidnapping
all of that said we can't be certain the
yabo brand which was handled by Channel
technology in the Philippines and which
sponsored Manchester United was in any
way connected to the cross-border
gambling yabo based in China
in fact the only connection we could
find between chanyu and China at all was
a trademark application
a Chinese company tried to register a
yabo trademark in China and was rejected
but tianyu managed to register the same
trademark in the same year in the
Philippines
that didn't help us much but looking at
trademarks gave us much more more 10 new
brands to investigate and a whole new
line of inquiry
[Music]
thank you
looking at the trademarks that Xiao new
technology owned became apparent that
they didn't just own yabo but it also
registered a whole number of other
brands that had sponsored football clubs
it was quite interesting once you
started looking at it because the brand
ownership would shift
on the 1st of August 2022 HTH and Leo's
trademarks passed directly from chanyu
to another Philippines based company
called Boe United Technologies
and just a day later yet another Manila
company applied for the yabo trademarks
previously held by chanyu now it doesn't
mean that this company is the real
company
no they're just the holder of of the
licenses and the trademarks but they're
owed by somebody else which is owned by
somebody else which is owned by somebody
else up till the moment where as per
usual you hit the wall and you can't go
further than that but at least we have a
proof that those companies are related
as we continue to look into this one of
the curious things that we found out was
that in fact Chan Yu and the other
owners or the registrants of the various
Brands weren't in fact gambling
operators they were service providers
for gambling operators which again lead
us the question well if they're only
providing Services whose money are they
actually using and in this case we found
that it was another company sitting on
top called infiniweb
infini web technology Inc seemed like a
ghost
the Manila address they gave to the
Philippines gaming regulator turned out
to be false their website could only be
accessed with the help of an agent we
did find several Facebook posts where
Infinity web Representatives could be
seen donating money and supplies to
police stations across the Philippines
but none of those receiving the
donations were able to offer any contact
information for the company itself
then there were the company documents we
couldn't find them for Infinity web
technology Inc anywhere in the
Philippines but we did find them
somewhere you can probably guess the
British Virgin Islands
throughout this entire investigation the
BVI has been the end of the line in our
various searches for brand owners so at
the end of it all we still don't know
who's behind Zella and 138.com
or in Fini web and a host of Brands
still operating under Boe United
Technology we don't even know the full
involvement if any of Sun City and for
the clubs the license providers and The
Regulators who have to deal with these
Brands that's a problem
[Music]
the fact that it's difficult to uncover
who owns these entities how they are run
you know how much profit they're making
are they paying taxes where are they
putting their taxes I mean clearly this
is this is something that needs to be
looked into a lot more telling us just
the brand is one thing unless we really
know who are the companies that are
providing money who are behind those
companies and whose money or where is
this money coming from how do we know
for sure that the money is clean how do
we know for sure that the due diligence
has been done for me any company which
hasn't got any transparent chain from
operator to owner it's not right it's
definitely not right there is a way for
these companies to operate in the
British Market but completely outside of
British corporate regulation these can
become International operations far
beyond the reach of a gambling regulator
or a law enforcement organization the
problem for enforcement against illegal
betting is one simple question where
does the crime take place to get proof
we would have to I think probably invade
the British Virgin Islands Caesar all
the computers and ask a team of
Specialists to go through every single
company that is registered there to find
out the names of who actually owns the
thing
we've gone into a lot of detail in this
film Brands shell companies license
providers trademark holders but why does
any of that matter because for 10 years
now these tools have been used to
conceal the true identities of some of
football's most visible sponsors not
just in the Premier League but in
leagues across Europe we see the name
the brand but we don't know who's behind
it or how it's being paid for from a
legal and transparency perspective that
should be concerning for all of us but
there's another simpler reason why this
information should be in the public
domain fans everywhere deserve to know
[Music]